you've had and I hope still have a
friendship with Elon Musk
especially over the topic of AI you have
a lot of interesting ideas that you both
share concerns you both share uh well
let me first ask what do you admire most
about Elon
uh well you know
I had a lot of fun with Elon I like Elon
a lot I mean Elon I knew as a friend I I
like a lot and um
uh you know I've you know it's it's not
going to surprise anyone I mean he's
he's done and he's continuing to do
amazing things and I think he's um
uh you know I think of many of his
aspirations are realized the world will
be a much better place I think it's it's
just it's amazing to see what he's built
and what he's attempted to build and
what he may at build and so with Tesla
was SpaceX was yeah I'm a fan of almost
all of that
I mean there are there are wrinkles to
to a lot of that you know or some of
that
um
and humans are full of wrinkles there's
something very trumpian about how he's
acting on Twitter I mean Twitter I think
Twitter he doesn't he thinks Twitter is
great he bought the place because he
thinks it's so great I think Twitter's
driving him crazy right I think he's I
think he's needlessly complicated in his
life and harming his reputation and
creating a lot of noise and and harming
a lot of other people I mean so like he
the thing that I objected to with him on
Twitter is not
that he bought it and made changes to it
I mean that was not uh again I I remain
agnostic as to whether or not he can
improve the platform
um it was how he was personally behaving
on Twitter not just toward me but toward
the world I think when you
you know forward an article about Nancy
Pelosi's husband being attacked not as
he was by some lunatic but
that it's just some gay gay tryst gone
awry right that's not what it seems and
you link to a
a website that previously claimed that
Hillary Clinton was dead and that a body
double was campaigning in her place
that thing was exploding in trumpistan
as a conspiracy theory right and it was
having its effect and it matters that he
was signal boosting it in front of 130
million people and so it is with saying
that you're you know you're you're
former employee yoel Roth is a pedophile
right I was like that has real
consequences it appeared to be complete
and now you could this guy's
getting inundated with death threats
right and Elon that's all that's totally
predictable right and he's so he's
behaving quite recklessly
and there's a long list of things like
like that that he's done on Twitter
it's not ethical it's not good for him
it's not good for the world it's not
serious it's just it's it's it's a very
adolescent relationship to real problems
in our society and so my my problem with
how he's behaved is that he's
he's purported to touch real issues by
turns like okay do I give the satellites
to Ukraine or not do I do I minimize
their use of them or not is this should
I publicly worry about World War III or
not right he's doing this on
Twitter right and
uh at the same moment he's doing these
other very uh impulsive ill-considered
things and he's not showing any
willingness to really clean up the mess
he makes
um he brings Kanye on knowing he's an
anti-semite who's got mental health
problems and then kicks him off for a
swastika which I probably wouldn't have
kicked him off for a SWAT stickers like
that's that's even like can you really
kick people off for SWAT stickers is
that something that you you get banned
for I mean that are you a free speech
absolutist if you can't let a swa
sticker show up I'm not even sure that's
enforce an enforceable terms of service
right there's their way their moments to
use SWA stickers that are not conveying
hate and not raising they're the risk of
violence clip that yeah any but so much
of what he's doing given that he's again
scale matters he's doing this in front
of 130 million people that's very
different than a million people and
that's very different than a hundred
thousand people and
so when I went off the tracks with Elon
he was doing this about covid and
um again this was a situation where I
tried to privately
mitigate a friend's Behavior
and it didn't work out very well did you
try to correct him sort of highlighting
things he might be wrong on yeah or did
you use the Lex power love method I
should I should write like a pamphlet
for Sam Harris well no but it was it was
totally coming from a place of love
because I was concerned about his
reputation I was concerned about what he
I mean there was a twofold concern I
could see what was happening with the
tweet I mean he had this original tweet
that was uh
I think it was panic panic over covet is
dumb or something like that right this
is wait this is in March it's early
March uh 2020. oh super early days super
early so when nobody knew anything but
we knew we saw what was happening in
Italy right it was totally kicking off
um God that was a wild time that's when
the toilet paper was totally wild but
that became the most influential tweet
on Twitter for that week I mean it had
more engagement than any other tweet
more than any crazy thing Trump was
tweeting I mean it was it went off
again it was just a nuclear bomb of of
information and I could see that people
were responding to it like
wait a minute okay here's this genius
technologist who must have inside
information about everything right
surely he knows something that is not on
the surface about this pandemic and
they're reading they were reading into
it a lot of information that I knew
wasn't there right and I and at the time
I didn't even I didn't think he had any
reason to be suggesting that I think he
was just firing off a tweet right
so I reached out to him in private and I
mean because it was a private
the text conversation
um I I won't talk about the details but
I'm just saying in that's the case
you know among the many cases of friends
who have public platforms and who did
something that I thought was dangerous
and ill-considered this was a case where
I I reached out in private and tried to
to
um help and genuinely help because it
was just it
I I thought it was harmful in every
sense
because it was being misinterpreted and
it was like okay you can say that panic
over anything is dumb fine but this was
not the how this was Landing this was
like non-issue conspiracy there's gonna
be no covet in the U.S it's going to
Peter out it's just going to become a
cold I mean that that's how this was
getting received whereas at that moment
it was absolutely obvious how big a deal
this was going to be no or that it was
going to add minimum going to be a big
deal I don't know if it was obvious but
it was it was obvious that it was a
significant probability that it could be
a big I remember in Mar it was unclear
like how big because there were still
stories of it like it's probably going
to like the big concern the hospital is
my overfilled but it's gonna yeah in
like two months or something yeah we
didn't know but it was there was no way
we weren't going to have
tens of thousands of deaths at a minimum
at that point and and it was it was
every it was totally rational to be
worried about hundreds of thousands and
when Nicholas christakis came on my
podcast very early you know he predicted
quite confidently that we would have
about a million people dead in the U.S
right and
that didn't seem you know it was it was
you know I think appropriately hedged
but it may was still it was just like
okay it's just gonna you just look at
the you we were kind of riding this
exponential and we're and
it's going to be you know it'd be very
surprising not to have that order of
magnitude and not something much much
less and
so anyway I mean again to to close the
the
story on Elon
um I could see how this was being
received and uh I tried to get him to
walk that back and then we we had a
fairly long and detailed uh exchange on
this issue and
that so that intervention didn't work
and it was not done you know I was not
an I was not
I was just concerned you know for him
for the world for and you know
um
and then there are other relationships
where
I didn't take the again that's an
example where taking the time didn't
work right privately
um there are other relations where I
thought okay there's just going to be
more trouble than it's worth and I just
just ignored it you know and there's a
lot of that and I and I Frank again I'm
not comfortable
with how this is all netted out because
I I don't know
if
you know I'm not you know frankly I'm
not comfortable with how much time in
this conversation we've spent talking
about these specific people like what
good is it
for me to to talk about Elon or Brett or
anything I think there's a lot of good
because those friendships listen as a
fan these are the conversations that I I
um loved
love is a fan and it feels like covet
has robbed the world of these
conversations
because you are exchanging back and
forth on Twitter but that's not what I
mean by conversations like long form
discussions like a debate about covid
like a normal day but there's no there's
no Elon and I shouldn't be debating
covert you should be here's the thing
with humility like basically saying we
don't really know like the Rogan method
right we don't we're just a bunch of
idiots like one is an engineer you're a
neuroscientist but like it just kind of
okay here's the evidence and be like
normal people that's what everybody was
doing the whole world was like trying to
figure out what the hell what yeah but
the issue was that at that so at the
moment I had this collision with Elon
certain things were not debatable right
it was just it was absolutely clear
where this was going it wasn't clear how
far it was going to go or how quickly we
would mitigate it but it was absolutely
clear that it was going to be an issue
right the the the the the train had come
off the tracks in Italy
we knew we weren't going to seal our
borders
there were already people you know who
there are already cases known to many of
us personally in the U.S at that point
um
and
he was operating by a very different
logic that I couldn't engage with sure
but the logic represents
a part of the population and there's a
lot of interesting topics that have a
lot of uncertainty around them like the
effectiveness of masks like yeah but no
but where things broke down was not at
the point of oh there's a lot to talk
about a lot to debate this is all very
interesting and who knows what's what it
broke down very early at
this is you know
there's nothing to talk about here like
it like it's like either there's a water
bottle on the table or there isn't right
like
it well technically there's only one
fourth of a water bottle right yeah
so what defines a water bottle is it the
water inside the water bottle is it the
water bottle what I'm giving you is an
example of is worth a conversation
this is difficult because this is we had
an exchange in private and I want to
sure I want to honor not not uh
exposing the details of it but
um
you know the details convinced me that
there was not a follow-up conversation
on that topic on this topic yeah that
said I hope and I hope to be part of
helping that happen the Friendship is
rekindled because one of the topics I
care a lot about artificial intelligence
you're you've had great public and
private conversations about this topic
and yeah Elon was very formative in my
taking that issue seriously I mean he
and I went to that initial uh conference
in Puerto Rico together and it was only
because he was going and I found out
about it through him and I just wrote
his coattails to it you know that I that
I got to
dropped in that side of the pool uh to
hear about these concerns at that point